Houston with your current book make your
story really stinking big you have a
chapter entitled build your characters a
house to live in
yes we talk about a little bit that
entails yeah absolutely so what what's
interesting now is from a transmedia
perspective from a super story
perspective the The Producers Guild of
America has ratified a transmedia
producer credit and they they ratified
that a few years ago and they say you
need three story lines and at least
three mediums that all operate in one
narrative universe and that one
narrative universe is what I call story
world and so now to be able to approach
a transmedia project or any sort of
project we we now need to not just think
about the individual story that we want
to tell we need to think about the place
where the story takes place the world in
which the story lives and that's what I
call a story world and that's that one
narrative universe that the pga talks
about and so there's a difference
between story world and story the the
story of Dorothy and the tornado and
Landon and oz and and going on the
adventure of the the yellow brick road
is a story but the story world is Oz
itself that is much bigger than then
then Dorothy Dorothy's just a single
story that takes place in a much bigger
world Luke Skywalker is just as his his
epic journey to destroy the Death Star
and you know the the story of the
dysfunctional Skywalker's the Skywalker
family is just a single story in a much
bigger world the story of the matrix is
neo and Morpheus and and their adventure
trying to deconstruct and tear down the
matrix itself but the story world of the
matrix is a futuristic earth that's been
taken over by machines and they use
people's batteries and put them in a
weird VR environment as they use them as
batteries that's the world of the matrix
which is much bigger than just neo and
Morpheus the story that's just one story
that you can tell and so now we're I
look at at not just what the individual
story is but what's the story world that
we need to build around that story
because what happens is if you if you
build your story world ride one it'll be
more attractive to an audience
remember one of the two reasons that
Spielberg told said that that Star Wars
was so much more valuable than Close
Encounters is because he said that that
Lucas built a world where people wanted
to explore and so the story world is a
key component in in multi-platform
success because that holds the rest of
your story potential so one it engaged
is more engaging for the initial story
that you want to tell but also it
creates more potential for more stories
moving forward so it if we put it into a
consumer like a consumer model and if
your individual stories if you look at
them as commodities and so my individual
story is an orange and I need and I need
to sell my orange in order to get money
and this is my business and if if I just
have if I'm holding oranges I could
probably just only only hold a couple
individual oranges and to take them out
to the side of the road to sell but if I
want to sell more oranges I need a box
and if I have a big box now I can have
30 40 50 60 oranges depending on how big
my box is then I can now take to the to
the side of the road to sell my oranges
and my orange stand so the box
having the box to hold my oranges
increases my revenue potential for my
venture the story world is the box that
holds your individual stories and so
some of some story roles are very big
like Star Wars like Star Trek like Game
of Thrones and Westeros that there's
these gigantic story worlds other story
worlds are much smaller but at the same
time they can still hold multiple
oranges which increases revenue
potential so these are the things they
get attract investors and attract buyers
but we have to look at the building of a
story world as a separate discipline of
telling a story and it's something that
that most people don't look at as a
separate some of the separate discipline
or a separate style of creation because
just because you're a good storyteller
doesn't mean you're a good world builder
just because you're a good world builder
doesn't mean you're a good storyteller
you need both
in order to to succeed on sort of these
these big levels but but but so in my
original book make your story really
stinking big I outlined some strategies
of world-building of its not building a
world and telling a bad story that won't
work because if you build a great world
until a bad story your products not
going to be any good you know I'm a fan
of a big world's big you know I grew up
Star Wars
Lord of the Rings type of stuff so I I
like these big worlds but you look at
something like the Wachowskis when they
did Jupiter ascending and that was a
tremendous world that they built but the
movie was very was was was not as good
as the world which ultimately made the
project just not sustainable and so you
can build a great world but if you have
a bad product that you put out bad movie
bad book bad TV show it's just not going
to work if you tell a great story with a
bad world you could win an Oscar but
you're not going to be able to extend
the life of the project and be able to
do all the other things that you want to
do because your your multi-platform
potential and your revenue potential and
your stored potential all reside in the
story world itself so so now we need
both we know these two things that we
need to be able to tell what I think is
a 21st century story is we need a great
story world and great stories within
those worlds that's what's great about
the Hunger Games the world the Hunger
Games is really interesting and cool and
but at the same time Katniss's story
within that really cool world is
emotional and engaging and something
that people can all get behind Harry's
story and Harry Potter is interesting
and emotional and we want to follow that
but the world behind Harry is just a
school in a rule of thumb that I use is
if you can take out your main character
and what's left is really cool and
interesting you probably have a good
story world so like we can take Katniss
out of The Hunger Games and Panem which
is the story world is still really
interesting and cool even without
Katniss it's really cool if you take
Batman out of got out of Gotham we're at
bat
Batman you look you have Gotham Gotham
is such an interesting story world they
have a TV show Gotham that that doesn't
have Batman in it it's it can sustain on
its own
you take loose guy walk out of Star Wars
arguably you've made it better a lot of
people think he's the most annoying guy
in there so there's other characters and
other interesting things that you can
follow same with Game of Thrones same
with all these things even something
like Deadwood on HBO Westworld the
leftovers
I love these all have like dynamic story
worlds that aren't big Star Wars worlds
but they're really interesting
well-crafted stories that if you take
out I'm a big fan of the leftovers you
take out Nora
and you know in Kevin you take out the
main characters the rest of the world is
interesting same with West world the
same with everything but if you take
rocky out of Rocky right then you just
have Philly you know and I like 1970s
Philadelphia which you can see the
difference right and so and so now what
happens is that whole brand around Rocky
is only bit is built on severe still
owns aging shoulders and you can't get
away from him in other trying to pass
the torch to Creed and that was good but
but you can see where they've been
limited because they didn't build a
great story world but they want an Oscar
right and so my thing is let's win an
Oscar and build a great story world
around it so we can extend and expand as
much as we want and so in that original
book make your story really stinking big
I outline some strategy in my new book
you're going to need a bigger story then
I even go into more strategy about it
because what we've seen in the past
couple years is is there's been a
there's been a premium put on how to
create great story worlds from
independent creators that when they go
shop stuff when they go shop a spec
script the scripts that have great story
worlds or have been getting
disproportionately good deals then as
opposed to the the scripts that are good
that she'll have good story worlds so if
you look at the spec deal
the average spec deals say is $200,000
$250,000 the specs that have great story
worlds
have been getting picked up two million
dollars three million dollars two and a
half million dollars because the studios
that look at those they'll say that has
one good story in it but this other
thing has one good story plus forty
other stories that I could potentially
tell across platform so I see video
games I see TV I see multiple features
that see cartoons
I see comic books so from a studio's
perspective all of a sudden spending two
million dollars from 40 stories rather
than 200 thousand dollars on one story
is a better is a better buy it's like
going to Costco and buying in bulk and
so if they think if they if I can buy
the big IP that has lots of story
potential now this is a wise long-term
investment for us and so I just I just
took two projects to China and over the
past you know a couple months and went
over without a script and sat with
oscar-winning producers who said we
don't really look at things without
without a script and I say well let's
let's talk about the world that I built
let's talk about the world where all
these stories are going to take place
and all of a sudden I get an attachment
from a producer again attachment from
the biggest director in China I get an
attachment from you know another from a
person that used to run a studio over
there that's coming on as a producer
then all of a sudden I'm attaching all
these people I don't even have a script
I just have this really interesting
world that I've built
where they see all the different story
potential and all of a sudden now
financers come find it and and then
riders look at it and say I would love
to write in that sandbox I want to play
in that sandbox and so it's a really
interesting time now in the marketplace
where the story world has has has taken
its own separate spot in the marketplace
it hasn't has an overtaking story in
priority because again if you don't have
great story your products not gonna work
but the story world as being a separate
asset as being separately built and and
have its own its own style of creations
own
rubric of creation that has really been
coming into prominence with with sci-fi
project fantasy project but at the same
time very very like real world based
projects that that you know you see an
HBO that you that we you know dramas if
you have a good story world then it has
good good story potential which means
has get a revenue potential and shelf
life for all the different players
within the within the project so in my
new book I go into greater detail
because of this sort of this change in
the marketplace of the store world being
a separate asset even go into you know
probably 50% more styles of creation and
things that you should think about
little tricks of the trade that really
help you whether you're building Star
Wars or you're building your one hour
domestic drama these are the things that
can help you help the revenue potential
the world itself so then when you set
the table with the world you can jump in
and tell this amazing heartfelt
emotional story then all of a sudden
you're hitting on both fronts and your
project actually has now has more
potential both financially and
creatively well that was my question
actually reading my mind because I was
thinking with real world I don't I
wasn't seeing how transmedia would work
if you take let's say the 80s films of
John Hughes sure fantastic movies
what worlds aside from like suburbia in
nineteen late 1980s could really be
there or the high school dramas of you
know Molly Ringwald or something yeah
you know because it seems like yeah with
with science fiction or some of these
comic book films there's endless
possibilities for these worlds yeah but
is their endless pasar they're endless
possibilities for a drama or even take
Silicon Valley great show or maybe maybe
they're more so but if you look at some
of the films of you know that are more
drama based or you have an romantic
comedy sure are their chances for a
world oh I think absolutely because I'm
in Silicon Valley is the the is a great
example because outside of the specific
characters in the Silicon Valley show
Silicon Valley itself the world of
Silicon Valley is very interesting and
fascinating the way that whole thing
runs and the people who reside there you
can see more than one story than just
you know handful of characters right and
so now you're just it's taken the Google
Earth view of of a story and saying what
I have right here is that is that
interesting so you could have something
like like rocky for example you know
right I say right you take rocky out of
Philadelphia
well if if I wanted to try to retrofit
transmedia around rocky I'm gonna have
to try to figure out the story world of
rocky and so now I'm gonna look at okay
Philadelphia and then I'll say okay well
what is it about Philadelphia that
what's the most unique thing about Rocky
I think the most unique thing about
Rocky is the fact that he was he was an
untrained boxer he's not even just an
untrained boxer he's he's that he
started out as a leg breaker for the mob
who then becomes a boxer who then takes
on the champ so he's a guy that has been
he's a guy that is not trained for the
industry that he wants to go into and
against all odds is able to overcome all
that and succeed at the highest level so
then I would say okay what is it about
maybe there's other people that live in
this other this part of Philadelphia who
do the same thing remember there was a
movie invincible Mark Wahlberg was a he
was a bartender who tries out for the
Philadelphia Eagles and makes the
Philadelphia Eagles based on a true
story that I think is a similar thematic
and a similar high concept is rocky
somebody who's not trained to go into
the industry that they want to go into
and against all odds overcome that
obstacle and succeed at the highest
level and so maybe I start to look at
the different parts of Philadelphia and
say you know there's fish town in
Philadelphia there's a part of
Philadelphia that that rocky some is a
part of called the devil's pockets it's
a little like suburb not a suburb but
like a like a little borough almost of
Philadelphia so then I can say okay what
is it about the people who live in the
devil's pocket part
Philadelphia and and there's something
about the grit and determination of just
how you the people who live there in the
day-to-day struggle and the lives that
they live and and what they do to
survive every single day that gives them
the grit and determination to say you
know what I can do anything that I want
to do I can be a boxer if I want I don't
care if I'm trained or not because I
grew up in the devil's pocket I know I
can do all these amazing things I can be
I can play for the Eagles
maybe you can tell a story about the
about a you know somebody what's become
a ballerina that is you know former drug
dealer out of a gang that wants to
become a professional ballerina
Flashdance exactly anything like that
the we're now now this this world the
devils pocket this little part of
Philadelphia is creating people with the
guts and the moxie and the grit that
where they can go out and against all
odds achieve everything they want to do
now maybe rocky balboa has the feature
films but then maybe there's a book
series about the ballerina that you want
to tell maybe there's a whole musical
extension that you want to tell about
somebody who wants to who wants to
pursue music
maybe there's a video game about
somebody else that wants to do something
and now we've identified this is a
really interesting world and then we can
tie all those stories together because
if you look at something like well it's
just on NBC Chicago fire Chicago med
Chicago PD
Chicago everything though all the
Chicago says on NBC they're all set in
one story world and then they cross over
and so they're all set in Chicago and
they all cross over in some really
interesting ways that's not transmedia
cuz it's all TV you don't shift your
mediums but the story world of Chicago
supports multiple stories of multiple
people and and then allows you to
crossover in some interesting ways if
you look at Chicago even you have you
have all the great stories that have
been told in Chicago from the 8 min out
which was the old baseball movie with
Charlie Sheen
there was about the old Chicago Black
Sox that threw the World Series 1918
baseball movie set in Chicago you have
Glengarry Glen Ross as a business movie
set in Chicago you have less natural
bloom
killers started in Chicago as a horror
movie like a serial killer movie in
Chicago you have Meet the Fockers one of
those was in Chicago you have divergent
and insurgent which is post-apocalyptic
Chicago you have the lose the Will Smith
movie I Robot I Robot set and futuristic
Chicago so what's interesting is all
those stories exist within the same
story world just in different parts of
the timeline right so from 1918 all the
way to post-apocalyptic dystopian
Chicago and so those all exist in the
same story world which now now if you're
thinking as a broader vision of a
project you say what is my story world
what is my you know if my story world is
is is Philadelphia or Chicago or
whatever now how do I explore the people
that live in that world but now also how
do I shift back and forth Lin timeline
to find other stories that I can figure
out how to then tie in because then all
of a sudden if in if in irobot the main
character finds a there's something that
they find in that world that then gives
them a clue as to who actually through
the World Series back in 1918 now you
tie this story that's a sci-fi story
back to the old baseball story that's
over here on the timeline and you're
connecting everything in an interesting
way and it becomes a game for your fan
base so it's not always about the big
Star Wars you know thing it's about how
do I identify a part of our world that's
interesting and cool that and sometimes
you have to engineer that right and so I
can engineer like that the neighborhood
where rocky grew up in as this
neighborhood that churns out other
people like rocky that have similar
stories maybe in some in different
industries and to be able to explore it
across platform now that's just as much
as a story world as Harry Potter maybe
it's a smaller box to carry the orange
and maybe it's as sort of a different
genre but it's the same principles that
build it
you